And there's going to be people [inaudible]
the leftist compassion when they
support China and death camps and, and
you know, you're wearing the left's I'll,
oh and passion, right? We can't hurt
anyone's feelings. We're helping arrest,
fall on gung and sell their organs
that we're Google and stuck to me.
You're right,
you're right.
The left has giant flaws that has
giant flaws and it's ridiculous ideas.
No, I'm against war. I am too.
And so now you've seen national
studies show this Gallup poll,
Democrats now support war
more than Republicans. Well,
this is about what this is about.
Pulling out a series.
I was trying to get denuclearize and
everybody's loving it and South Korea and
Japan and North Korea and he's actually
got him to not fire missiles to destroy,
declares the real,
the real problem.
There's a real problem in people not
being able to say that anything that Trump
does is good. If a Democrat was doing
what Trump was doing on some issues,
I disagree with some.
I would support them.
I don't give a damn what their
deer or are well and so and so.
Then Trump got rid of the,
he's getting rid of the minimum sentences.
I mean Hillary Clinton, you know,
w o God, I saw this the other day. I don't
know, I'm ranting, but I was watching,
I forget to who the top Democrat was.
They were on CNN and I'm a political but
my show and I didn't do it. And they,
and they go, they go, they go,
president Trump thinks blacks. Yeah.
The clip was she an in CNN says
Trump thinks blacks are stupid.
And it was a CNN panel going,
Trump says blacks are super predators
who have to be brought to heel.
And Joe, that's Hillary Clinton in
1994 after she passed the crime act,
that's her quote.
So they are inverting reality knowing
our talking point as she did that and we
have the video type in,
Hillary says blacks are super predators.
Say said Trump did it. It's not about
Trump, it's that he didn't do that.
Okay. But let's get back to what we
were trying to say was that if you,
if he does anything good, no one can
accept it cause he's on the wrong team.
That's part of the problem with,
with what's going on.
It's part of the problem with people
willing to accept ridiculous shit on the
left and people willing to
accept ridiculous shit on
the right is that we get on
a team and that the people
that are on the left,
they can't admit if the
economy is going well,
they can't admit if think they will.
Bill Maher said, let's crush it on me.
Oh I dunno. Uh, you know, I
don't know you like I listen,
I've been on his show before
and I talked to him once.
We did a show together once with Craig,
nobody can lie and say that
he's not very talented and,
and that he's more his tie. He's more
truthful than most leftist. He says,
I want abortion, I want death. [inaudible]
he's a comic of telling you man,
the shit that he's saying. He's only
saying cause he thinks it'll work.
And I don't by the way,
just show with his,
but why would he be the highest
ratings ever gotten on? Invite me on?
I don't know man.
You'd have to talk to him.
But what I'm saying is when he starts
talking, like people are saying, Oh,
Bill Maher's mocking the red states.
He's doing a bit,
he's doing a bit like you thought.
There's funny in that. That's all it is.
Like if you, if you've talked to
him about his legitimate opinions,
he's capable of having a conversation
about legitimate opinion of an aggregate,
but you could disagree or
dealers or wrong on that point,
what would you say that the red
states want to be? The blue states,
the demographic show the
opposite, I think. Is this a joke?
A really do I don't think even
means it. I mean, if he does mean,
and I disagree with them by the,
let me show,
let me have a basis to let me
have a beef with you on this.
And I'm not saying you're wrong because
everything I've learned is great.
There's a, there's mixtures
of everything. Yes.
And by the time I go to the next
spot, I forget the last thought, but,
but the point is,
is that,
is that what we're saying was that he
was doing a joke about the red states
wishing that they were the blue states
and you were saying that that's wrong.
And I was saying he's just fucking around.
He's like product and that's it.
That's it. Mainstream news is
getting as very low writing.
She can mean went down to
almost nothing and they go, oh,
ratings are up in the Trump era,
like a dead cat bounce.
It's like 10% of what
it used to be lurking.
You should have 15 million viewers now
the top scene and show us a million show.
We're looking at that. This is the
future. This is the, this is the,
this is where the people are real
things. Not scripted. No teleprompters.
There's no teleprompters here. This is
real. And so they get up on television.
I'm literally having Alzheimer's.
What was the point again?
We were talking about Jesus Christ.
One problem. Here's the thing,
here's the problem with no teleprompter.
I am literally,
I literally tell you what's in my brain.
The do just like my truth doesn't mean
I'm accurate. It doesn't mean I'm perfect.
It means I'm telling you
when I really thought,
oh I don't want to fucking around.
I know what it is.
No one's watching mainstream news. No
one's watching mainstream news. Sure.
But let me tell you what they
are watching the big five,
the nightly comic shows and comedy
central shows, the daily show, Trevor,
Noah, Stephen Colbert, all those guys,
cause they want some relief but it's,
it's not been, they want relief, right.
I used to watch their ratings are down.
It's still on a span as you know, as, as,
as other stuff because now
that no one's watching news,
Sean Hannity do really well is in his
show only Fox because it's seen as
alternative. Just like, oh but, but
what I'm saying is well promise,
I'm not articulating this well. It's the
truth. It's not like some package thing.
They have turned all of the so called
comic shows into fake comics posing as
fake news. People putting out political
commentary, which people take it as real.
And believe on the street.
And so that's where all the propaganda is.
And so you say, Bill Maher's just joking
around. Bill Maher's just over here.
Bill Maher does what he's doing.
It's all a unified message.
They have Stephen Colbert and then lean
upon her and say that I'm a KKK member
and make jokes. And you know what people
shouted at me on the street. Well,
that's unfortunate. Um, but what, what I
will say about what they're trying to do,
they're not trying to deliver information.
They're nuts.
They're trying to crack jokes. I guarantee
you there's a whole writing staff,
kind of all the shows that the Democrats
call them and tell them what to right
now. I don't know if that's true, but
if it is as true and they do listen,
that's not good. And that's
unfortunate. It's like, Oh,
you host the man show with Doug. Stan
hope. No, the other guy, uh, nothing.
Uh,
there's Jimmy Kimmel and Adam Carolla
says he gets calls every day from Chucky
Schumer and then they, then they work
on what he says he's television show.
This is what's so frustrating. He might've
been fucking around though. No, dude,
it's talking points, man.
Okay. I believe you. I believe.
Yeah. When he, I don't know,
lost Jimmy Fallon went from being
funny to being totally weaponized.
So you think it was nbcs idea? Do you
think it was someone in the government?
The contacts? NBC says, tell
Jimmy Hours are very well known.
UFC fighter that you know. Okay. Who has
shows on discovery and history channel?
I'm not going to say his name.
Okay.
And I got a call about a month ago and
they're like, wow, this is incredible.
Don't say my name. You can talk about
it. They were gonna offer me this new,
big lucrative show.
But they said,
you're going to come out and announce
Alex Jones on the show or we're not going
to give it a show. And he said,
no show. Hell yeah, man. Huh?